after years of waiting the batman has
finally swooped into theaters it's been
a long road for this new version of the
dark knight to make its way to the big
screen as a production was hit with
pandemic-related delays and setbacks
robert pattinson himself reportedly
caught covert 19 during filming so it's
a minor miracle that warner brothers has
finally been able to release the matt
reeves directed movie thankfully the
film pushes its cast of dc heroes and
villains in new directions many of which
should even surprise longtime fans the
action kicks off in bruce wayne's second
year of crime fighting so audiences
don't have to sit through yet another
origin story when a sadistic individual
called the riddler starts targeting the
corrupt officials of gotham batman sets
out to stop his violent war before the
villain can hurt the rest of the city
the caped crusader also crosses paths
with some other iconic characters from
the batman mythos as he gets help from
lieutenant james gordon and catwoman aka
selena kyle he even goes up against two
other iconic bad villains penguin and
carmine falcone who are at the heart of
organized crime in gotham that said
there's never any doubt to the big bad
of this film is when it comes to the
film's cryptics you're your killer
director matt reeves and co-writer peter
craig take a new approach to the riddle
obsessed villain before we go any
further be warned spoilers ahead let's
get the most obvious change out of the
way first the riddler's new duds gone
are the days of bright green spandex
with question marks painted all over
no this version of the villain takes a
more tactical approach to his look he
sports a dark green military jacket with
a similarly coloured hoodie underneath
then there's his incredibly creepy mask
that he wears with transparent glasses
over the top to mask his real identity
which we'll get to later on after the
first teaser for the film arrived back
in august 2020 comics writer nick
darrington took to twitter to point out
that riddler's headgear is actually an
extreme cold weather mask used by the
u.s military so why does riddler take a
diy approach to his terrifying look well
for starters he doesn't have the same
funds as bruce wayne to create a
high-tech suit so he probably shops in
army surplus stores for his gear let's
not forget that this version of the
villain is much more of a homegrown
terrorist than jim carrey's gleeful
mischief maker in batman forever he's
also a huge departure from the sharp
suited version of the character in the
gotham tv series the small screen's
riddler is also a former gcpd forensic
scientist although he clearly enjoys
taunting gotham in his live streams a
flamboyant eccentric riddler wouldn't
fit into this universe that matt reeves
is building the riddler also tells the
hero that his mask allows him to become
his true self it's all an attempt to
bond with batman as he points out that
the caped crusaders persona is also his
true face it's the classic with the same
you and i approach to connecting the
hero and the villain there's another
surprising difference in the riddler's
character from what dc fans might expect
his name isn't edward nigma this time
around the villain uses his birth name
edward nashton a choice that's mainly
about making sure these characters feel
natural to the world of the batman the
enigma joke wouldn't work as well here
it just feels kind of silly sure
nashton's job as an accountant is a real
reason behind his roaring corruption in
the first place but the riddler persona
is who he really is plus he's already
projecting majorly enigmatic vibes even
without the pseudonym when the police
eventually managed to arrest the riddler
his wallet is filled with a couple of id
cards so they're not 100 sure who he
actually is riddler's detached
personality his unhinged crimes and his
bizarre costume even called back to a
real life serial killer when speaking to
movie maker reef said the premise of the
movie is that the riddler is kind of
moulded in an almost zodiac killer sort
of mode it's easy to see the connection
since a riddler sends messages written
in code much like the zodiac killer who
terrified san francisco in the 1970s
thankfully alfred pennyworth happens to
be a master code breaker which is hugely
helpful when he and bruce are picking
apart with those cryptic messages
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite dc movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you